ce sont des images qui donnent le
vertige cinq ans de guerre vu du ciel
des kilomètres de désolation des
quartiers entiers défiguré un aéroport
mais d église en ruine
un drame humain au coeur même de
l'europe des civils pris en otage
abandonné 1
lina habite plusieurs mètres sous terre
dans ce vieil abri nucléaire soviétique
avec trois autres femmes qui était veuf
bien avant la guerre il le rester au
moins leur maison leur jardin et le luxe
de vieillir en paix ce sera leur sixième
hiver ici fait toujours froid humide et
le temps est long et c'est le seul
endroit sécuritaire explique vera elle
raconte que deux de ses voisins sont
morts leur maison pourtant ne sont pas
loin tout près d'une mine de charbon qui
constamment ciblés par la retirer
ukrainien photos choc sur le nuit là bas
non peuple nous allons bientôt la fin du
mois d'octobre dans lequel elle a
construit ses amis la console en vain
labrie nucléaire devait être une
solution temporaire mais on ne voit plus
la fin il dira ça fait longtemps que
l'instinct de survie a enterré le débat
politique
mais il leur arrive encore d'essayer de
prédire leur destin ce sera aux
politiciens décider dit elle nous tout
ce qu'on veut c'est que la guerre
finisse pour sortir d'ici vivre
tranquille et revoir les enfants en paix
dans la rue
là
à 11 ans macha a passé plus de la moitié
de sa vie sous les bancs
son école se situe à 2 kilomètres
seulement de la ligne de contact à
gorzow cas immeuble a été lourdement
endommagée mais retaper plusieurs fois
ces heures passées en classe ont
sûrement les plus sereines élan que
c'est tout n'est jamais loin
hier christophe dreux voiles chimiste et
la liste officielle d'hommage reste t il
et je t'avais shirdi seraient commis et
je t'avouerai chine pays bas llodra
sacha lui vit de l'autre côté comme on
dit en territoire contrôlé par les
forces ukrainienne ils traversent
régulièrement la frontière pour venir à
l'école territoires pro-russes
quand on lui demande comment c'est là
bas il hausse les épaules initialement
il parle russe mais il ne comprend pas
pourquoi les deux côtés se livrent une
telle bataille c'est dur comme réalité
quand on vit si près de la ligne de
contact de la vice directrice
vous imaginez on leur enseigne les
oeuvres de pouchkine des leurs manteaux
mais on doit aussi leur apprendre
comment distinguer les types de but
parce qu'on veut on doit les garder en
vie ses enfants
car plusieurs élèves ont été tués par
des éclats d'obus alors qu'il rentrait à
la maison
le pire c'est le soir à boston
macha sort mais cette fois c'est pour
nourrir les pôles que la famille a reçu
de la croix sa grand mère nous montre où
elle a trouvé des explosifs en cueillant
light
puis les trous sur le toit de la grange
dans leur petit village la vie confinée
à l'intérieur avec un livre ou devant
l'ordinateur
un autre cadeau reçu d'un groupe
humanitaire elle regarde en boucle cette
vidéo d'un garçon qui récitait un poème
au sol de la région
chaque fois ça m'arrache le coeur dix
bêtes là n'a comme de zinc ou djce
aujourd'hui on veut leur enfance et
celle de mam achats elle ne voit pas
comment la région pourrait un jour
revenir sous la gouverne de l'ukraine
vous croyez 90 nationalités et tenez moi
plus agent yanis mallorca vous chassent
la russie leur offre des passeports mais
elle n'en veut pas tout
reste nourrie par l'espoir d'un cessez
le feu pour l'amour de dieu prix
ludmilla hilton nous guy laroche et
quand il y en a des mauvais temps ils
menacent taïmyr tu as mangé ni rouge
attaque nous le dira qu'avec le show
tahiti à l'attaqué d'arhab à riddes et
utah
elle veut la paix
et sauver ce qui reste de leur identité
sur cette terre disputé où même les
morts ne peuvent plus reposer en paix